Well,
hello friends, Héctor Mejía greets you with
his brief information for today, Wednesday
, March 24, in two weeks, all
people over the age of 16
will be able to obtain the
coronavirus vaccine, the Southern Nevada Health District
asks everyone to  be
eligible to make an appointment and get
vaccinated now sites like catch
minds at the convention center and
university and at vip say they have
appointments available
now that more checks are being
mailed las vegas police
' le  offers the public some
tips on how to avoid getting scammed
so be careful check your mail daily
you can also sign up for a service
called webber report and that service
will send you pictures of what you expect to
receive in the mail if you plan to go out
of state you can put a  stop your
mail until you come back this way
nothing important is left stuck in your
mailbox
the hybrid learning model in the
schools of the cis jus  t and it only started
a few weeks ago and parents
say it is causing problems for
students for them
face-to-face classes are in the morning in the
afternoon they are done virtually
those students with
extracurricular activities say it is not
possible to go home for later  having to
return to the establishment yes yes I am it
says that the schools are
responsible for finding a place so that
these students who attend
activities can also study
in person parents who want to
discuss this issue should contact
the assigned school directly
now we are leaving  to the weather forecast
the winds will finally calm down this
afternoon maximum temperatures in the high
centers for today wednesday the strong
winds from the northwest will be
cooling our temperatures for the
next few days have an excellent
wednesday I am hector mejía and this was
your short
training session  Spanish edition
[Music]